what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey from podcast
one
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone
we just become best friends yep
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of
unwaxed here with sophia and sistine
okay i actually kind of wanted to start
out um i have a really bad headache
why because so it sounds kind of stupid
but
i have a pimple on my forehead and i've
been really excited to get rid of it
let me just explain this i'm actually
pissed off that this happened
um and it was starting to fly now but i
was reading my phone
laying down with my phone yeah above my
head and
the phone could have fallen out anywhere
right it could have been my cheek
it didn't have to fall period it felt
but it did i butter fingers you know me
and not only did the phone land on my
face
the corner just hit one spot zipping
below
zipping balls not only
did it rain come back it came back as a
bruise
wait do you see it does anybody
see it it's a boulder i think i put on
like
why did you tell me that i'm only gonna
be looking at that spot now
has anyone noticed i put on like eight
layers of makeup and it's still
forming it's coming back
it's cute um i think we should talk
about we've been getting a lot of
messages about
um what happened after i
snuck in and saw sophia on her date with
this guy
yeah um i'm gonna tell you what happened
because i don't know if you guys
remember
a couple weeks ago sistine surprised me
by telling me that she booked the same
restaurant and time as a guy that i was
going out with
because i wanted to meet him and i
thought it would be funny so we're here
to tell you if you haven't heard that by
the way go back and listen to that story
time
and then come here thank you we're going
to tell you what happened
so i'll just explain in the beginning i
right when i was walking to the
restaurant i said to the guy hey
just warning you my sister's inside not
a big deal
but she booked the same restaurant in
the same time to me
not creepy not stalkerish not stalking
not a big deal
so i am sitting at the table i've got my
three other friends with me
and i'm i see them and i'm so excited i
don't know what to do i put my napkin on
my face because i just i got nervous
so i'm holding up my napkin and i'm
trying to be funny we instantly make eye
contact when she's walking in and i'm
sort of doing a like
a peekaboo you know like a peekaboo with
my napkin
trying to be funny act like i don't see
them and i'm kind of excited someone you
know what like
if he's if he doesn't like like my
sister then
i can't go out with you or if she
doesn't like yo no sorry if
she doesn't like him then i can't go out
with you anymore and so i already warned
him
told him what he was getting into you
guys approached the table
and what happened sistine and it
was awkward it was
right off the bat i'm trying to be funny
he didn't laugh strike one
not at all it was funny and uh
i go hi my name is sistine and i reach
out to shake my hand he shake his hand
he shakes my hand he doesn't really
introduce himself to anyone else at the
table
no not at all like cisgender friends
there and it was only a group of like
three people
yeah it wasn't like intimidating he
looked almost
like a deer in headlines like yeah just
very taken back by it
and i remember him kept keep saying to
me like hey
let's go to our table let's go to our
table and i'm like what is happening
yeah
you know what like for a first
impression you're meeting the sister it
wasn't
as engaging that great as i would have
liked it to be
so i sit down and i'm facing sistine his
back is facing the state's table
all i see in the background is the scene
doing this thumbs
did he know that you were back there
doing that no no his back is backwards i
would
never do that but that's like that movie
moment where he's constantly gonna be
like what are you
yeah what's going what's back there and
this is the problem i'm not
very subtle with my movements and
gestures so i guarantee he
knew that i was looking fine but so so
i said all right shaky start you know a
little bit rough
let me wait till they have a cocktail in
them loosen them up a bit
i'm gonna go in for a second approach
but let me just say this
when we sat down the first thing he said
to me was
you bamboozled me
and i go what you mean bamboozled you
and he says that i surprised him and he
wasn't expecting that
other than the fact i told him that we
were going to meet you
so i didn't know this right she didn't
know this so my dinner's over
they have their first course sophia's a
few cocktails then i can tell
oh yes right it doesn't take me a lot i
go up
and i go let me try again and i try to
be funny
i bring over a waiter act like i have a
waiter's towel on my arm
trying to take their order and again
he didn't think i was born by the way
this kid is a funny guy he actually that
was one of the things that attracted me
to him
so it was almost like he was avoiding
eye contact yeah i don't know so i go
or was he attracted to sistine oh shut
your mouth so
yeah was he intimidated by your beauty
all right let's just i think it's funny
that his word of choice was bamboozled
oh is he 75 you bamboozled me that's
that's literally what we were saying the
entire night this is when it gets worse
not only did he say he was bamboozled
once by me
he thought to bring it up maybe three
more times
with that exact word on three different
occasions remember that time
your sister bamboozled me i'm feeling
bamboozled
why'd you bump the whole time like we
bamboozled you with me
so i don't know if you guys realize this
or not but it didn't go well
so cysteine and i went
violin uh i go home i we
end up just like not really hanging out
after that i was just like i need to go
home i don't i'm tired
so i avoid him the rest of the week i
just he's texting i'm giving him short
answers
the vibe is off i'm not really i don't
think i need to give a name i feel a
little guilty
yeah because i kind of well okay she by
the way the reason why we're not
working out is because cysteine that is
not true no the reason why it's not
working out is because
he made a bad first impression i did a
great job no i'm saying
because because you don't like him it's
hard for me to like someone that you
don't like
you've been also i don't like the fact
that he didn't just go along with it who
cares you know
my dad a few days later sophia and i are
at a mexican restaurant
on like a tuesday night and we're
drinking a few margaritas and we said
it's time to drop no no i would no back
up
he texts me that paragraph and goes hey
it feels like something's off
you don't seem like you're into me why
do we why are we talking like we're
drunk right now
we literally what was going on i'll just
word vomit it basically he was like i
can feel some things off
it's not really working out or it feels
like it's not working i really like you
like what's up maybe i'm just reading it
wrong so christina are
two cocktails in definitely not sober
enough to formulate a really good one
but we're like you know we we can think
of a breakup text so right
i always find the best way to break up
with someone not over text but if you
are going to do it over text
is to write it in your notes section
first so you can edit it
you can you know with it a little bit
but we didn't do that in the beginning
but then you
while we finished it we copy and pasted
it yeah yeah but we put it in notes
before
and um thank god we did because
when we read it back sober
why don't you read what we would have
sent to this kid
so this is what i wrote to the guy
no i've been pretty bad at replying the
feeling is mutual
i've had so much fun getting to know you
right now
i'm not looking for anything serious
i've had so much fun getting to know you
and it's definitely nothing you did but
i'm not looking for anything serious yep
did i stutter i just think we needed i
think
you know we mentioned the repetition
just to make sure he knew
i hope he ever knows that i had a lot of
fun with him not looking for anything
serious
but though i'm not looking for anything
serious i had a lot of fun
like you were following i mean you don't
make a show you know but that looks
it's very clear about what i felt
so thankfully i screenshotted that sent
that to my friend to draft and she goes
absolutely not so basically she
formulated something
yeah was good sent it out uh and now
i don't know what he's doing and then i
thought best way to blow
like soften the blow of a breakup oh
yeah send a gift
so i sent it so i said sophia send the
gif
of spongebob doing this with the finger
guns like and he's leaving the room
nothing and leaving now
so i sent it and then i sent the gift
with spongebob
snapping his face and that's it and
we're single again we're back to square
one
all right for the record that gif
unequivocally if communicates
[ __ ] off yeah we have left the chat
so but real quick before we bring on
manny we have some
super exciting news for you guys and
listeners
yes we are giving away a 200 gift card
to the amazing clothing brand called
saltwater lux
to a lucky listener of unwax okay
you guys so all you have to do is
subscribe to
podcast on apple leave us a rating and
review
and with your ig handle in the review
and follow our page on wax podcast on
instagram
and the deadline is september 30th so
guys go to apple
rate review and subscribe follow us on
instagram make sure you have your handle
and the deadline is september 30th and
look sophie and i are not gonna promote
a brand
that we don't actually like very true
i'm telling you these clothes are
actually chic
you want to go from brunch to beach to
night out
you can i love this brand it's like boho
it's cool we look hot gervious but also
comfortable classy little sassy you go
on a date
yeah you have a night out water lux 200
bucks come on
free money people you don't want to miss
this okay you guys today we have
the youtube o g with us he has
a strong presence in the beauty
community with his 4.8 million
subscribers
subtle flex he is the founder and owner
of lunar beauty has been featured in
forbes 30 under 30
and was the first male ambassador for
maybelline
we have the iconic manny mua
oh you guys are so sweet your entire
intro is
my dream do you understand that i've
said for years i was like i want to be
on forbes
i want to be on the cover of something
with you let's talk about that because
sophia
her dream mm-hmm probably once a week
she'll be like i'm going to be on forbes
30.
i'm managing no way i love that right so
how did that happen for you honestly i
don't even know how it happened that's
the real gags i'm like how did this even
happen like i remember getting the call
and they were like
you made it to forbes 30 under 30 and i
was like why
and i literally was like wait why
because i'm so like not the type of
person that's like
are you the right man like no i'm
literally just like oh but what'd i do
like what did you know like what did i
is very much that but
you know it's been cool because like i
feel like when you're in the social
media space like you just grind and
grind and grind and grind
right good things just happen but you
don't like expect them to happen because
you're
just like okay i'm just trying to like
make good things happen for myself
you're not expecting
i'm not expecting it yeah i'm just like
wanting to do it for fun wow did you
ever like was there any expectation when
you were going into the beauty world to
like
what was a goal of yours before i think
my goal was really just to
you know like make it more of an even
not even much more like
gender neutral space like yeah that's
like what my goal was i didn't want it
to be just like a
a female dominated space it is still
which is totally fine but like i just
want i didn't want it to seem like i was
a girl or like i was transitioning to be
a woman or anything like that i tried to
show that makeup was for everyone and
makeup could be a
artistic outlet for you because that's
what it was for me you know
that's so interesting that you say that
that it's a female dominated
area because i only watch um men doing
makeup tutorials i'm not even kidding
like
no it's true there's something about
like your hand is just so
freaking fine and detailed i'm like i'm
watching this i know it's and you give a
better description by the way yeah
more detail so that actually i think
would be a good segue into talking about
your brand lunar beauty i want to know
them amazing
the name what how did it thank you yeah
so so lunar beauty like the name of it
i've always been obsessed with sailor
moon which is like an anime from back in
the day
that was like literally my obsession um
last night we were just talking about
halloween costumes and we're like we're
obsessed with sailor moon
stop yeah i thought it was i literally
was sailor mars for halloween one year
like you guys don't understand like
she's a screenshot of the photo i have
like anime eyes on me oh
like i have like tattoos of see the moon
so um that was just like i've always
just been very very fascinated by that
and i was always a night owl so i'm like
lunar beauty just kind of flowed
yeah and it just made sense so the
things that i created were like kind of
inspired by that in a way like i have
these highlighter compacts that are
called moon prism
um highlighters instead of like moon
prism power so just kind of like
playing one word like from sailor moon
so it was always just really really
inspired by
like the night sky and you know like out
of this world beauty that's like our
slogan it's like out of this world
beauty lunar beauty
yeah yeah it's been it's been crazy like
i actually work with my parents on the
full time they're like
you work with your parents yes they're
like full time like they're like my so
supportive i love that
yes no it's crazy because i i'm like the
ceo but my dad's like the c-o-o
or cfo my mom's a ceo and it's like holy
crap i get like literally deuce with my
family
wait how long have you been working them
with your family on this since like the
beginning because we are sisters and
we're working on this show together and
it's it's different when you work with a
family member on a business i mean how
is it working in a family honestly
it's great but it's also hard at the
same time because sometimes you're like
okay like are we on right now
are we in work mode or are we in like
family mode yeah because you know
because you know almost like never know
because like you can just be chilling
having dinner like wait did you do that
right you do that did you finish that
and they're like oh my god like we're
not even working do you guys ever get in
fights because when you're with family
members and working with them especially
you know you can jump on each other much
easier yeah right and you can call them
out it's so much easier to jump on them
because it's like oh i don't
i'm not scared of hurting your feelings
so do you guys think i don't know we
don't really fight a lot though because
i feel like we tend to like
talk it out pretty well and like they're
really organized both of them are really
really organized so i don't really have
to like
be on them like i thought i would i'd be
like oh my god like who's done this
email
and there was like oh it's already been
done i'm like oh right okay great i mean
being an entrepreneur and getting into
that whole industry is kind of a scary
transition you have to have a lot
of self-confidence to get get even
started with that i mean how did you
even
did you just know right off the bat this
was my opportunity to get into it or
were you just
just jumped in with your family you're
like this is something for me
i was so like a goal of mine was always
to have like
my own makeup line you know i always
really wanted that for years and years
and years before even i was like
this is so cool i've always thought of
like i feel like for me like my creative
mind goes like creating makeup like i'm
not i can't draw
i can't paint i can't do all these
different things but i can't do makeup
well
and i can create makeup and that was
like my artistic freedom kind of like
realized into a product so
for me it was like how do i express this
and create
things that people would actually
genuinely love right and not like
gouge people and like that was like the
whole point for me was like i feel like
all these huge corporations i just have
like these ceos that are like massive
and these crazy boards and stuff like
that like they're just
putting out stuff that's not really good
just to get money from people and like i
was like okay well i'm going to
put a high quality gorgeous product yeah
and people will know that i'm like
actually testing them out myself and
like i'm a makeup wearer
i reviewed makeup i've been doing it for
years and like i know if i'm testing
something and like i'm
trying it my best that it's going to be
good well i've seen your products and
like the way you're describing it you
can really tell
that you did put your soul and your
heart and your passion into it
so where can people find lunar beauty
luna beauty.com is where you can find
all the products i know what we're gonna
do after this we definitely need to go
check it out
we'll literally send you stuff like yes
so i want to talk about a little bit
your early life
and i was reading somewhere that you
were raised mormon
can i say that my best friend that i
grew up with
she lives in utah right now she's mormon
yes i
was kind of almost raised in that
household with them
and it's so different from anything i've
ever experienced i mean the whole you
can't have coffee
no alcohol the um the special underwear
the missions all that stuff i mean so
how was that
upbringing for you when you living in a
mormon household you know people always
like asking this they're always like
okay like was just so crazy
and i was like i actually had like an
amazing time growing up and like
because i feel like especially because i
grew up in san diego right so like i
didn't grow up in utah i didn't grow up
like super super strict household like
it wasn't
like that for me and i think that maybe
because like i'm like a i don't know
maybe like a hybrid board
i don't know what it would be but um you
know for me it was super super chill it
really was like the church was really
about like family values and that's like
all that i ever like really took from it
especially was like
being with your family you know that's
like your unit making sure that
everything is like good with your family
and that's what i've taken from you
especially growing up mexican like
i'm already like so family knit in the
culture totally
this was just like you know just extra
just solidifying like the family bond
and that's like literally all it is
to me and so i really enjoyed it it was
hard obviously growing up gay and like
in the church there's like a lot of
inner turmoil yeah i want to ask about
that
yeah you know that's definitely
definitely tough and i think it's hard
because you almost feel like
oh my god am i sitting because i'm gay
like you know you know you never know
but i feel like for me
yes there's so much pressure on it
especially when you're that young
because it's like i would be like
literally like praying the gay way when
i was like nine like i was like no i
don't think boys are like boys like
right
cry and pray just like can i please just
not when i wake up you know and i was
super super confused and
i didn't even accept it till i was like
15 16 years old were your parents
right off the bat super supportive they
were confused
they were really like they didn't really
understand it they thought it was a
choice right they never really had gay
friends growing up they just thought
like oh like why are you choosing this
and i was like i'm
not so they just took a long time of
like
in the gravy into their mind that
something like i don't have any control
over like i literally was like born this
way
yeah you know it's not something that i
can just like unlearn it's just like in
innately in my dna right you know and i
think that um it took a long time for
them to get that
because they were really confused they
just they also like especially like 10
years ago oh my god
10 to 15 years ago like in san diego
there was so much gay hate crimes and
like hill crests and things like that
and
they were so scared they're like no you
can't be gay they're gonna get attacked
yeah so they're just trying
to try to protect me so i totally
understood but it was it was hard
because i'm like dude you guys don't get
me you guys don't understand me and it
was just like this constant battle with
them
of like when you guys gonna like get it
through your heads you know my mom was
more accepting like just mom's just like
it's your mom you know it's like she
just gets it and my dad it was a little
more difficult for him to accept but
you know i feel like time is just one of
those things like it just time heals
those wounds and like
it's so true it just it's like the
constant just
exposing and i think that's like what it
really really takes especially for
parents that have no idea about the gay
world it's like dude you just have to
like
want to figure it out for yourself and
for your family you know my parents both
were like
we love you so much and we want to
understand like what you're going
through and so they tried
you know it's like i tried they tried to
and we met in the middle and it was
great and we have a great relationship
they do something like really
loving they are they're so they're so
loving and they're good
yeah i mean that's it is such a scary
feeling to have to open up and you
really don't know the outcome of it
and then you said you did it at 15 right
yeah like i
i remember it was i was like more
personally realizing it when i was 15. i
think it was like when i was 16 that
like they
asked me like so do like boys i remember
i like left over i like literally left
open my laptop
on the in the living room and i was like
flirting with a boy on myspace
back in the day wow that was how yes i
was like
with the boy but not even realizing i
was 30 i was just like oh like what's it
like to kiss a boy because i knew he was
bi
right and i was like oh like that's so
strange like how weird but i was like
kind of flirting too
so just like asking questions right i'm
just like oh like what's it like
and so they had like saw it like i left
i thought i closed the thing i did it
they came back and like my mom was
there my dad was there my mom was crying
and i'm like what
in the heck did i just walk into and i
like we all honestly just had to
melt down all of us and i was like yeah
gosh i am i don't know if that's
good that you kind of just ripped off
the bandage right honestly yeah and it's
nice because they
asked me it wasn't even like me having
to like go up and muscle the strength
and tell them i was like no they
literally asked and i like
finally broke down oh my gosh and then
speaking of growing up
did you right off the bat love makeup or
was this something that you just started
to yeah because i know that i
grew to love makeup watching my mom
because she just did like
your mom too because my mom every single
day she's this signature like sexy yes
yes smudgy and i was like oh my god at
like 15 i was wearing a cat eye
no totally ridiculous so your mom was
your major she was my yeah she had like
had her little vanity she would get glam
every single day
before work so she was very much a glam
girl and she still is she doesn't leave
like the house
my mom says if you ever leave the house
looking bad you're just never going to
know who you run into
every time i leave the house looking
like [ __ ] you see your ex-boyfriend
you see the person that you don't like
and you're like this is like but i love
this
mom with the full glam she was always
just like i want to put my best foot
forward always
and so i always just like took that as
like that's really really awesome that
she
gets to choose what she wants to do you
know whether it's with makeup or without
like she can
have the option like oh i want to just
look more presentable today or i want
this and this and you can like
alter your appearance right and be like
oh i look a little tired so let me
add some concealer yeah yeah i love that
that was like that was my favorite part
about makeup when i was
getting into it was like oh i can like
really like do some fun things i want to
be a plastic surgeon when i was younger
no
my wow that was to be a plastic surgeon
and so i was when i i got my bs in
health science and um at sdsu
and i was like going to want to med
school you know that's like yeah that
was my goal
um so but i love that aspect of plastic
surgery was like getting to change
something if you didn't like it and if
it just
felt like you wanted to change something
and you could you know and
there's nothing wrong with it it's just
like oh it's just personal preference
it's like subconsciously you knew what
you wanted and you
knew that maybe whether it was makeup or
plastic surgery you wanted to have the
option to change yourself like
non-surgical non-surgical yeah
absolutely and it was just like it's all
about like
feeling your most confident in the way
you want to feel it like i think that as
long as you're doing it for you and
for the right reasons like do whatever
you want so you you express that through
makeup yeah so now i trust it through
makeup
it's not surgery you know
yeah so is that when you decided okay
i'm pretty good at makeup
maybe i should make a youtube video and
upload it so i so
so what it was is like i started working
at sephora inside jcpenney that was like
oh my gosh i was i was a waiter for like
two years okay and then
the restaurant that i was working i was
like we're gonna close in a week so you
guys are about to find new jobs and
we're like
what everyone like all the waiters are
like we're [ __ ] that's stupid it was
so stressful
and so we um a friend of mine had posted
like on facebook like oh my sephora's
hiring and i had liked makeup i had done
drag a few times just like with friends
yeah and i was like oh like this is
really fun i enjoy it so i remember
applying
even though i had no experience i was
like okay i'm just going to apply this
okay
and i remember going in and it was
before it opened right and it opened and
i was gonna go
do my interview but someone came in and
she came up to me she was like oh can i
like do you recommend something for like
i have oily skin i want like a primer
and i was like
oh my god i don't even work here
so i went and i sold her this primer by
i think benefit and i was like yeah this
would be fantastic and she bought it and
i was like
i just sold a product out there without
like without even working there
yes and i got hired
and i got hired because i got awesome i
got hired at sephora said jcpenney but
my parents didn't know i worked
for foreign because like they accepted
the like they were finally getting
around the gay thing but the makeup
thing on top of it
how old were you working at sephora this
is like when i was 21. i still lived in
my parents house so like really
my parents might really like their now
you're gonna pretend working at jcpenney
you're working at sephora how long did
you keep this secret
i literally was living a hannah montana
life i'm not kidding like i would
literally get glam in my room
locked my door jump out my window i
swear to god
i'll jump out my window go to work at
sephora just painting do my thing yeah
come home drive home take off all my
makeup with like wipes in the car
and get into the house we're like yeah i
just got back my shoes that's so much
work
uh-huh it was literally so many
did you get caught or did they did they
caught my makeup instagram so i had like
created a makeup instagram that i had
blocked all my family members from
literally every family member that i had
i blocked every single one of them so
how did they catch you someone at church
like this is your son i was like they're
i don't know
that's the mormon because they're so
tight knit it's tight knit but i was
like so someone from
church you're like your son wearing
makeup
and i was like i'm gonna kill myself oh
like i literally said i remember like
they were like you have to delete it
and i was like no i'm not deleting it no
and like no they're like you have to
delete like
like because i was like obviously like
doing jcpenney but i was like
in school wanting to do plastic surgery
go to medical so like what would
what would medical school say about they
see you like have this random i was like
i don't know like who knows
who cares yeah you know but they're just
like you just never know like what
people are homophobic
and i was like like you have to delete
it and i was like i'm not deleting it
and so i told him that i wasn't deleting
it but they're like you're going to lead
i was like
no i'm not and so for like a while i
ended up still having them blocked and
they thought i did delete it but i
didn't did you just block more people
from the church
and you just kept vlogging
yeah i just kept blocking and blocking
until i didn't have anyone else to block
and i kept it and then
um i remember i showed my mom a message
one day and i was like look at this like
little boy he like sent me this message
like of how like and i inspired him in
some way to like be himself
and just like kind of be creative and
just like fine and she was like very
very
um like blown away by that and i showed
my dad too and they were both like wow
this is
yeah something that's really helping
people and i was like yeah it's like
something that i enjoy and it's helping
people
your youtube career today is huge right
and i think
you know oftentimes the more following
you have the more
haters you get because you do get a lot
of positive comments totally but you
also get a lot of people speaking
negatively about you
and that can honestly affect you
personally and emotionally and i think a
lot of people don't realize
you know someone's sitting behind a
computer they think they have all the
power but
the words hurt and so how how do you
deal with something like that
i think at the beginning it was actually
a lot harder for me like in the
beginning of my career i was like oh my
gosh
these cups are so mean and you know
there's so many
people out there that just don't
understand you and like they
like they also don't even understand
themselves too because i feel like a lot
of times that people project their
hatred onto others when they're not
happy with themselves and so
i think that it took a long time to
realize that usually when people send
you hate
it's like them really hating themselves
because no like
sane normal happy human being is sending
hate comments to people online like that
they don't know no
so i think that it just took a while to
realize that but then once you realize
that you're kind of like oh
okay like it's not me it's more so them
right um and like you know especially
when you're
doing your thing like you will find your
tribe like you'll find your people that
like
that [ __ ] with you in like a good way
you know and i think that that is
something that i found like i found my
following that like really resonates
with me
yeah and i think that as long as i have
that like i'm good and yeah of course
haters will come and go but
i have like my people so like that's
like what i do it for i don't do it for
like the haters
i do for the people that like actually
support me and like that want to
see me succeed and i want to see them
succeed as well have you been cancelled
or
talk a little bit about cancel culture
to you yes i have absolutely been
canceled it happened to me two years ago
um and i feel like at this point i'm
like a spokesperson for cancer culture
because like
i swear like everyone always asks me
about it and like i always get like
outlets hitting up like
we're doing something on cancer culture
we'd love for you to talk about it
because i've probably spoken about
cancer culture and how i think that it's
honestly i think it's horrible i think
cancer culture
in itself what it is is you know it's
people canceling someone for something
that they did and as if that you can
never come back from that as if you
could never
you know find forgiveness as if you can
never like make amends right i think
that's like the actual issue with cancer
culture is that people think that
you know the people that they're
counseling aren't human and they're not
gonna make mistakes and that they can't
rectify the mistakes that they've made
and i think that that's the important
part is i believe in holding people
accountable
yeah wholeheartedly you know like
absolutely you should be held
accountable for something but
to think that this person can't not make
a mistake
and their exiled forever is horrible
yeah i completely agree yeah
and just because you're a public figure
doesn't mean that you're
super human and can make it you're human
as well right and i'm gonna make
mistakes and like i think that people
need to realize that like
people are gonna constantly make them
and like just because you have followers
doesn't mean that you're not gonna make
the same mistakes that people make and
like listen i understand that
we are put on a pedestal in a way in
that we have a responsibility and it's
made me grow up faster than i ever
thought i would right because of it
because i'm like i want to be better for
my following
i truly truly do but that doesn't mean
that i'm not going to make human
mistakes that like we all
do yeah i want to touch on the sort of
fake friendship thing
have you dealt with a lot of people
using you for clout and people that
you thought were your friends and then
when you needed the most they just
weren't there
yeah absolutely i feel like i think that
everyone on social media kind of deals
with that a little bit like if they've
gotten any kind of
cloud or fame or whatever it might be
like a lot of people tend to not be
there for the right reason they just
think that oh well i'm just gonna like
climb that ladder you know what i mean
i've been accused of it too i've been
accused of like being that person that's
climbing the ladder you know constantly
and i think that
with social media it's like you know
back in the day it was all about collabs
right people like wanted to collab so
badly
that's how people grew right and like it
was a constant like social media like
the platforms actually
where like you guys should collab like
they would like make things happen
because i think we want you to continue
to grow each other
um but now looking back it's like it
just seems like
you're just cloud-chasing no totally i
mean that's like what it kind of is now
it's like cloud-chasing it looks like it
and that's why it's really hard to gain
friends within this industry sometimes
because you meet them through like maybe
work events or like collaborations oh my
gosh
it's so strange because sometimes i'll
go on a date and they'll be like
so uh your dad can you get us in a movie
i'm like
probably not right right right
yeah it's like that's like the annoying
part too it's like you never really
know like what people are in it for like
i remember i've been on something twice
i've been on a date
and after the day the guy was like so we
should collab sometime
and i was like i swear to god and i
literally was like this
is horrible would you say like two years
ago
you were sort of stuck in this like
manny social media person that's like
and you weren't really separating who
you are as an individual
100 when you were in that headspace did
you ever deal with like
anxiety because i know that sofia and i
with social media like
seriously we've seen and experienced
like it affects your mental health and
your your well-being and you're you're
almost like in this black hole of like
oh my god like i need to why don't i
have more followers why didn't i get so
many likes so
what was did you ever tell me about your
anxiety or do you have anxiety i do i
absolutely have anxiety and depression i
suffered that since i've been since i've
been young and i've been on medications
and things like that forever
um but absolutely i think that it's a
huge huge part of social media is like
anxiety and depression honestly i feel
like a lot of the leaders
and friends of them know have issues
with anxiety and depression and i'm sure
a lot of your followers didn't know that
right absolutely
and so they were almost judging you
totally and you almost don't want to
show that too much because you're like i
want to be this strong figure for all my
followers but then sometimes
to break down those walls that's when
you really can get to the nitty-gritty
and it almost makes it even
better a hundred percent did you ever
announce that absolutely and i've
created videos that were like
i'm i'm not okay right now like this
isn't like i'm not doing well like this
i need to just take a break take a step
back and i think that people
are understanding and i think that
nowadays like i actually think that
anxiety depression are like an all-time
high
so many people now suffer with an
anxiety impression i think that could be
social media
you know because i feel like a lot of
like social media is now a thing and
there's now more depression anxiety
okay how does that make sense what are
things that cause you anxiety for me
like it was
see nowadays it's different but like
back in the day when i was more honed in
on the social media world it was like
likes views other people's how they were
performing and how well they were doing
and comparing yourself constantly and
how they looked and like i don't have
that kind of body and it was so many
constant like comparisons
yeah i think that that is like actually
what a huge issue on social media is is
like constantly comparing
and i did that all the time i compared
myself it's impossible to know how could
you not yeah you know especially like
other boys in the beauty space i'm like
i would compare myself because like if
it's like something that i do
i'm going to constantly compare you know
what i mean i think that you know it's
important to kind of like for me like
after like even after the cancelled
thing like i went to therapy for like
six months after
because i wanted to like kind of again
focus like what i wanted to do and i
think that that really helped too is
like
finding help in different things like
you know whether it's like
anything therapy or painting or like
just like finding
peace and other things yeah that's not
online and like having your
phone turned off and you know it's funny
because i'm a social media person that
you would think i'd be promoting social
media but it's like you need to have
breaks
how do you get rid of those like what
ifs when you're like worried or anxious
about like taking that step forward or
like you don't believe in yourself that
much like how do you
get back to know i actually can [ __ ]
do this like i'm me i
no one else can do what i can do i think
that that is about having like a
like a good chord that you have and i
think that's about like having a good
core family
or friends or following like i think
that's the people that help you like
when you're at your
most weak to help you like go the extra
mile because it's like i have my inner
strength obviously i can do things
myself but
when someone else believes in you it
helps you give that extra little push
because it's like no you can do this and
you're like
you're right i can do this yeah but it's
hard it's so hard
when you're especially if you're drained
like especially if you're emotionally
drained physically drained you're just
like
i can't do it i don't want to do this
anymore i don't want to do it i want to
give up but it's like the people in your
life that love you
and like no i see something in you like
you're amazing you need to keep going
that's like
the extra push that you need so i think
it's all about having a really good
core people around you that you need
it's the biggest blessing to have people
around you that tell you you actually
can do it when you're at your lowest and
you're going i can't
exactly i mean the moments i've had my
friends are going oh you actually don't
i don't think i can see you doing that
that's really when i start to spiraling
yeah i really can't do it because if
they can't see it then obviously and i
can't
then i shouldn't do it which could be
totally the polar opposite exactly
that's the opposite like you would not
you don't want friends like that no your
friends are always going to motivate you
and keep you going and keep you pushing
with family members like you don't if
you have a family member that sucks you
don't have to be
with them all the time or you don't have
to choose your family you know like the
whole chosen family things
in the gay world that's very big is like
yeah a lot of times families don't
accept
their gay children so they have their
chosen family which is people that love
them for who they are and like that
becomes their family
so it's all about surrounding yourself
with people who actually
love you for who you are and what you
can do yeah and who want to see you
succeed
yeah yeah you give such good advice on
that because i feel like a lot of people
forget that that's
seriously the i think the most important
thing about life is really surrounding
yourself with people that love you
support you yes totally entirely
like what's the point of like honestly
for me i guess it's like what's the
point of having everything if you don't
have someone to share with
that's like what i've always just said
like literally it's like i don't i don't
understand like what's the point because
it's like if it was just me and like the
house i live in right now right i live
in like
a pretty nice house like a 500 square
foot home like it's like me and my two
little brothers and like i get to share
that with them
and like i get to share like my success
with my family and it's like oh i feel
so great doing that and like that's what
i like
if i had all of this and it was just me
i'd be like depressed i love that manny
oh i think
we should wrap up one more funny
question okay yeah let's do it and i
want you to be as
honest okay as possible
[Music]
i need you to look at our faces and tell
us
what we can fix with our makeup and i
want you to be so honest you're like
[ __ ] you're oily tell me you're not
oily at all so i'll start with you
because i'm already looking at you right
now i have so much powder on let's see
let me see like my lips are crusty
honestly i i think it's like you have to
say something no i'm going to trust me
no trust me i'm going to absolutely say
something i'm going to be honest i think
that with you like i feel like because
you guys both have such good skin like
i'm telling you like even though yes
you've had the
boulder yes the boulder but like
honestly because i feel like with this
like when it comes to skin like your
guys is what it's so natural and nice
already you don't need a lot
to enhance your natural beauty i don't
know what i'm trying to say is like i'm
trying to wear almost less makeup now
because i'm like i don't know like the
reason i'm wearing this much is because
i
want to transform like that's like my
yeah i feel like when enhancing natural
beauty
this is like what i like to do you know
this is like more great like you don't
do you have any product in your brows i
don't even think you have any i do
do you i put uh gel tint okay cute i
like that
it looks honestly it looks really good i
honestly would just say like i would
probably carry
if you want this is like a cool trick
yeah if you guys want to make it look
like you guys have more makeup on than
you really do
bring the shadow at the top down here
under
underneath like to put like on your lash
line right there it just
it adds like just more of a pop oh my
god man you're such a beautiful person
you guys are too you guys are fantastic
as bright as your jacket
thank you you're so sweet i'm so happy
we met today with you guys
yes absolutely i agree i agree real
friends yes real friends like texting
friends yes
not like social media perfect okay go
plug all your socials right honestly
guys so you guys can find me at manumua
733 on all my socials in lunabeauty.com
yeah lunarbeauty.com [ __ ] look
at
that
it's bomb you guys i promise you it's
bomb the quality is amazing the
packaging is amazing
bye guys bye bye from all of us here at
the show
thanks for staying unwaxed no
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts at sophia stallone
and at sistine stallone and be sure to
follow the show at
unwaxed podcast your producer is will
sterling
we'll see you next week